[Música]
se cumple una semana de disturbios en
los territorios franceses de ultramar de
guadalupe y martinica en donde miles de
ciudadanos han salido a las calles en
rechazo a la obligatoriedad de la
vacunación contra el cob y 19 y el porte
del pase sanitario las marchas han
dejado cuantiosos daños y 90 personas
arrestadas
con 101 votos a favor 30 en contra y 2
abstenciones la cámara de diputados de
chile aprobó el proyecto que abre paso
al matrimonio y a la adopción por parte
de parejas del mismo sexo ahora sólo
resta que este proyecto sea estudiado y
votado en el senado tenemos reporte
desde la ciudad de santiago
y el gobierno de eeuu propuso retirar a
la ex guerrilla colombiana de las farc
de la lista de terroristas
internacionales esto coincide con el
quinto aniversario de la firma del
acuerdo de paz en colombia' en nuestra
serie de reportajes especiales
hablaremos del trabajo que desempeña la
unidad de búsqueda de personas
desaparecidas durante el conflicto
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos hasta
ahora comenzamos en francia en donde hay
expectativa ante el dramático aumento en
el número de casos de contagio por kobe
19 el país registró en sólo 24 horas más
de 30.400 casos son cifras similares en
que presentaba francia desde el pasado
mes de agosto desde la semana pasada los
casos se han incrementado rápidamente
hasta alcanzar un aumento del 79 por
ciento con respecto a semanas anteriores
el presidente francés emmanuel mayo se
reunirá mañana miércoles con un comité
ministerial para hacer seguimiento a la
situación y determinar así medidas para
enfrentar el repunte de casos
y se mantiene la atención en las islas
francesas de guadalupe y martinica
territorios franceses de ultramar en el
caribe en donde miles de ciudadanos se
han tomado las calles para protestar
contra la exigencia de la presentación
del pase sanitario y la obligatoriedad
de la aplicación de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 por parte del personal de salud
desde parís han intentado mitigar los
disturbios por medio del envío de
refuerzos para la policía local y la
imposición de la medida del toque de
queda que está vigente desde el viernes
ya unas 90 personas han sido arrestadas
barricadas se alinean en las calles de
la isla francesa de guadalupe las
protestas contra las restricciones por
el hobbit 19 entraron en su segunda
semana la obligatoriedad del pase
sanitario y la vacunación de los
trabajadores de la salud impuestas en el
país han provocado disturbios en la isla
francesa donde se han registrado saqueos
nocturnos y enfrentamientos con la
policía el ministro francés de ultramar
recalcó que es escandaloso no acatar las
reglas impuestas en el país luego de
publicar el orden republicano debe
volver y el ministro del interior ha
anunciado importantes refuerzos ya que
por las noches los agentes de la ley son
víctimas de munición real esto es algo
que no podemos aceptar y debemos
condenar la violencia no tiene cabida en
el territorio de la república ni en
guadalupe ni en ningún otro lugar en los
últimos meses guadalupe se vio afectado
por una nueva ola de casos de kobe 19
que abrumó a los hospitales además la
pandemia también ha devastado la
industria del turismo la desconfianza en
las vacunas y la medicina natural son
populares en el caribe francés el enojo
de la población por la nueva restricción
los ha llevado a preguntas más amplias
sobre la relación del archipiélago con
parís
no no es una buena respuesta del
gobierno porque nos obligan a vacunar
nos será difícil pero seguiremos
movilizando nuestro menos de la mitad de
la población de guadalupe ha recibido
una dosis de la vacuna lo que es
incomparable con francia continental
donde el 75% de la población ya está
inmunizada la atención también se
intensifica en la vecina isla de
martinica donde la policía fue atacada
con disparos este martes la denominada
cuarta ola de la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
impactado con fuerza en alemania país en
donde diferentes sectores políticos
respaldan exigir la obligatoriedad de la
aplicación de la vacuna las autoridades
también han dispuesto de dosis para el
refuerzo para las personas mayores
mientras que los que no están vacunados
cada vez se están enfrentando a más
restricciones en lugares públicos el
informes de andré amaya
alemany intenta frenar el aumento
descontrolado de los contagios porque
hoy 19 luego de 16 días de récords de
casos positivos el gobierno debate si
vuelve obligatoria la inmunización
contra el coronavirus el país tiene una
de las tasas de vacunación más bajas de
europa apenas el 68% de los ciudadanos
ha recibido la pauta completa razón por
la cual cinco jefes de gobierno
regionales ya se han mostrado abiertos a
considerar la obligatoriedad de la
vacuna durante una reunión de
representantes de la unión europea el
ministro de estado alemán abogó por la
dosis de refuerzo
tenemos nuevos hallazgos científicos de
que la dosis de refuerzo es un gran
éxito si las vacunas de refuerzo están a
la orden del día los estudios
científicos demuestran que la
efectividad de la vacuna aumenta
nuevamente de manera significativa con
esta dosis extra de man si usted está en
la ciudad de colonia centros deportivos
y de conciertos se convirtieron en
puntos de vacunación para los que
quieren esta dosis
mis sets quería recibir una vacuna de
refuerzo que se ofrece aquí y todavía
había citas disponibles venir aquí en
automóvil también es bastante cómodo
libre de mauro for fun can siempre
noticia muy bien en su intento
desesperado por proteger a los sistemas
de salud sobrecargados alemania y otros
países de europa imponen reglas que
limitan las opciones para los no
vacunados en la capital alemana sólo las
personas que estén inmunizadas podrán
acceder al comercio minorista con la
excepción de los establecimientos donde
se venden productos de primera necesidad
que seguirán abiertos a los no vacunados
aunque algunos mercados de navidad'
decidieron cerrar el de berlín seguirá
abierto nos vamos ahora hasta el extremo
sur de nuestro continente en chile- la
cámara de diputados aprobó el proyecto
de ley que propone el matrimonio
igualitario en una sesión que terminó
con aplausos los diputados aprobaron por
101 votos a favor 30 en contra y 2
abstenciones la iniciativa
aparte de las uniones se permitiría
también la adopción ahora sólo resta que
el proyecto sea estudiado y votado en el
senado la cámara alta de ser aprobado
chiles en el octavo país o territorio de
américa latina' que avala estos derechos
a sus ciudadanos patricia luna desde la
ciudad de santiago nos tiene más
detalles en el siguiente reporte
si él está un paso más cerca del
matrimonio igualitario tras que la
cámara de diputados aprobara el proyecto
un votos a favor 30 en contra y 2
abstenciones el proyecto deberá pasar
ahora al senado la cámara donde se
originó para un último paso y de ser
aprobado se convertiría en ley contempla
además la adopción por parte de niños
por parte de las parejas del mismo sexo
que tendrían los mismos derechos que el
resto de los matrimonios en el país el
reconocimiento de la maternidad a las
personas trans y las pensiones de viudez
para las parejas del mismo sexo el
proyector se retoma así después de
llevar varios años dormido en el
congreso fue ingresado en el segundo
mandato de michelle bachelet llevaba más
de cuatro años ahí esperando a ser
tramitado y sebastián piñera sorprendió
a todos en su última cuenta pública al
anunciar que le iba a poner máxima
prioridad algo que causó mucho enojo en
el oficialismo puesto que las fuerzas
conservadoras en el país se oponen al
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
no así la ciudadanía según expresan
varias encuestas además en la misma
sesión de la cámara de diputados- estaba
previsto que se discutiera el aborto la
despenalización a las 14 semanas de
gestación no puede ocurrir el tiempo
en la discusión del matrimonio
igualitario y quedará por tanto
postergada son dos temas que se discuten
en el congreso mientras en el país ya se
disputa la campaña por la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales que
opone a dos candidatos que tienen
también visiones contrapuestas en torno
a estos temas mientras que el
ultraderechista jose antonio kast
rechaza el matrimonio entre personas del
mismo sexo y cualquier tipo de aborto el
izquierdista gabriel boric se muestra a
favor de ambos proyectos
la misión de observadores electorales de
la unión europea se pronunció sobre los
recientes comicios estatales y
regionales en venezuela- la misión
encabezada por la diputada portuguesa
isabel santos indicó que persisten
irregularidades
estructurales como la inhabilidad de
algunos partidos y candidatos opositores
el uso de los recursos de las campañas y
también el uso irregular de los medios
de comunicación sin embargo señaló que
hubo también mejoras en los componentes
técnicos y en el consejo nacional
electoral que fue calificado como el más
equilibrado en dos décadas
y eeuu podría eliminar a la extinta
guerrilla colombiana de las farc de la
lista de grupos terroristas
internacionales así lo notificó el
departamento de estado ante el congreso
para exclusión de dicho grupo armado con
el que el gobierno colombiano alcanzó un
acuerdo de paz que fue firmado el 24 de
noviembre del 2016 en el marco de este
quinto aniversario el secretario general
de la organización de naciones unidas-
antonio guterres visitó colombia para
constatar los avances en la
implementación de este acuerdo de paz
seguimos hablando de colombia en este
país la desaparición forzada ha sido una
práctica habitual como arma de guerra a
partir de los acuerdos firmados en el
2016 en el marco de la justicia especial
para la paz fue creada una unidad de
búsqueda de personas
dicha unidad está conformada por
delegados de la extinta guerrilla de las
farc y también del gobierno nacional
luís muñoz y juan carlos zapata
periodistas de france 24 viajaron hasta
una zona remota en el oriente de
colombia para conocer el trabajo de esta
unidad especial veamos
y mi niña
de 12 años
se desapareció
mileidy yadira santana laura piensa
muchas veces que lo vivido forma parte
de una pesadilla cuatro hijos un marido
y un hermano están desaparecidos otro
hijo de 11 años fue asesinado lo mataron
a él el el 8 yo nos de la vida porque se
ensañó de esta manera conmigo si yo no
le hice mal a ninguno y si mi familia
hizo algo porque tuve que pagar yo
esto es duro y también algunos vivos
muy fortalecida
ya dices a dirige la comisión de
búsqueda de desaparecidos componente
farc del oriente de colombia y que vamos
a luchar incansablemente por encontrarlo
ese es nuestro lema
encontrarlos entonces ahorita este es
para muchos ex combatientes como laura
el único lugar al que pueden dirigirse
para reclamar a sus desaparecidos algo
imposible antes de los acuerdos de paz
de 2016 entre el gobierno y la guerrilla
de las farc porque yo nunca denuncie
nunca nada de ir a la deriva todo así de
miedo que porque pronto me mato bueno
yaritza lidera la búsqueda desde este
espacio de reincorporación de firmantes
de paz conocido como mariana páez jr
ubicado en mesetas meta han documentado
más de 800 casos que permitieron a la
unidad de búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas y el comité internacional
de la cruz roja a ubicar a más de 100
desaparecidos la comisión de la verdad
cuenta más de 100.000 desapariciones
forzadas por el conflicto un crimen de
lesa humanidad los ex combatientes
tratan de encontrar a todas las víctimas
del conflicto
los testimonios anónimos de excompañeros
una forma de reparación todos son
necesarios buscarlo porque su familia no
está requiriendo su familia está
sufriendo la ausencia los los ha matado
en vida ya dichas tuvo 30 años en la
guerrilla donde llegó a ser comandante
todavía guardar recuerdos como su diario
escrito en la cárcel tras ser detenida
en un bombardeo donde perdió a su pareja
con la nueva independencia nuestra
patria liberar y sentar un precedente
por toda la eternidad
yaritza tiene un hermano desaparecido
después de toda una vida armada en
selvas como esta vuelve ahora en su
misión de búsqueda con una nueva
convicción el firme compromiso con la
paz nos vamos ahora hasta el continente
europeo en otros temas autoridades de
bulgaria y de macedonia del norte
investigan las causas que provocaron el
choque y posterior incendio de un
autobús en el que murieron 46 personas
entre ellas 12 menores de edad otras
siete personas sobrevivieron a este
accidente el hecho ocurrió en la
madrugada muy cerca de la localidad
búlgara
los primeros indicios apuntan a que el
bus podría haber impactado contra la
barandilla de la autopista el ministro
de relaciones exteriores de macedonia
del norte se pronunció sobre este hecho
que ha consternado a esa república
balcánica
hoy el gobierno ha declarado tres días
de luto estamos haciendo todo lo posible
para identificar a las víctimas lo antes
posible para que las familias puedan
recuperar las algunas de las familias
están en sofía bulgaria esperando tal
vez de este proceso termine pronto
estamos en estrecha colaboración con las
instituciones búlgaras con los fiscales
y con la policía y mientras tanto en
áfrica extensa la situación de seguridad
en etiopía la onu concedió 72 horas para
la evacuación inmediata de las familias
del personal de ese organismo
internacional en ese país africano la
onu continuará monitoreando la creciente
amenaza de este conflicto que podría
alcanzar addis abeba la capital de ese
país de ser necesario la onu también
podría evacuar a su personal no esencial
si la amenaza en la seguridad se
incrementa
y días antes de la reanudación de las
negociaciones para reactivar el acuerdo
nuclear del 2015 alcanzado entre cinco
potencias mundiales más la república
islámica de irán el director del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica afirmó desde teherán que busca
un marco de entendimiento ante el
aumento de las reservas iraníes de
uranio altamente enriquecido y dan por
su parte pidió que se eviten presiones
políticas extranjeras
con y cambiamos de tema las estrellas de
la industria gastronómica de américa
latina se reunieron tras el
confinamiento que trajo la pandemia de
kobe 19 para revelar la lista de los
latin america fifty bester restaurant
twenty twenty one se trata del anuncio
de los mejores restaurantes de nuestra
región en su top top 10 destacó tres
restaurantes de lima perú dos de sao
paulo dos de ciudad de méxico dos de
buenos aires y uno de santiago en chile
el puesto número uno fue para el
restaurante peruano central un habitual
en este listado internacional
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias aquí en france 24 en unos
minutos la información económica siga
con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]